[Music]
welcome
everybody to the feed a corporate chess
championship i'm grand master robert
hess alongside me my friend national
master sam copeland
sam how you feeling today i'm feeling
really really good i'm looking forward
to this
this is an exciting format we were just
talking about how much we've enjoyed
playing in the us amateur team east
and this is like that times a thousand
in
numerous different ways so i think this
will be an amazing event with amazing
players like magnus carlson
anishigiri nepam nishi
so many great players alongside you know
all kinds of great amateur players
around the world who are making great
contributions to companies into the
world
yeah putting a new definition of work
from home because
of course with the worldwide pandemic
we're already working from home but now
you're doing chess so is that work is it
fun
unclear what each company has in store
for us but let's remind everybody of the
format
to let them know what we're about to see
here there is
the first stage which is the pool stage
which we're in now and
teams will qualify for the playoff and
each team has four players at least one
male at least one female
and they can have reserves they want the
10 minute plus two second increment time
control
it's this nice kind of rapid time
control where you
hopefully will not lose on time but for
some of our participants who may not be
so experienced in online play
that could still be very quick paced and
as is standard
one point for win half a point for a
draw no points
for a loss so sam as we move into the
you know start of this tournament the
pool stage here we have so many
different pools
swiss pairing system how do you make of
this as
you know thinking about putting this all
together
well it's really really going to be
incredibly challenging there are so many
teams participating i think 93
teams per pool and it's a six player uh
or sorry six round swiss system here so
you only have six rounds to get into the
finals
on sunday and to do that you're going to
need
probably a perfect score six points out
of six points in your matches
or at least five and a half out of six
and some very very lucky tie breaks so
this is going to be
extremely competitive you know we've got
these star players
but it's really going to come down to
the depth on the team
in almost every case for sure it's a
winner stay home type of dynamic
and well magnus carlsen is playing in
this event that's
in the buzz around the chess world he is
on the kindred team
and of course matched by his let's just
call him twitter
uh competitor anish geary for optivor
they have a rich
chess history uh they really love chess
they've been
working together for a long time anish
has helped train the team
he told me for this competition so maybe
some of those ratings of his teammates
or full-time employees there will be
misleading because they have that
geary method under their wings
absolutely maybe we've got some like
bingy fishy nico situations here where
anishikiri has really been uh
driving up the uh the skill level of his
uh
players in some close uh close uh
sessions here training sessions
it's going to be really really
interesting to watch these players kind
of represent these
companies that they've been associated
with for a very long time
absolutely and we do have some welcoming
words from the fedex president arkady
dworkovich
let's hear what arkady had to say
your participants of the first feeder
world online
corporate championship very happy that
more than 1
500 participants gathered today to
compete
for the first place but more importantly
to show the love for chess to enjoy
playing chess
and to collect best memories from this
championship
you have been surprised by the number of
applications for this
championship as it never happened before
and we have 280 80 teams competing
with more than 100 grand masters men and
women participating in the tournament
it's a great combination of skills
talents
and real joy here for our great
game we also happened
that companies were
trying their best to collect
the best players working
around their ecosystems and we will
have more and more partners in the
future more and more people involved in
playing chess and organizing chess and
partnerships
one of our initiatives that we got
support for
from you uh from the companies
participating is donations for our
social projects
including uh educational chess um social
chess and uh supporting our chess
veterans
thanks a lot we are very grateful for
your enormous support
good luck at the tournament and i wish
you good health
we are also thankful to our key partners
in this tournamentchest.com for
organizing the event and providing best
possible conditions for
all players all teams and finally good
luck the tournament and i wish you good
health
you heard from the feed a president this
event you know many corporations taking
part and also giving back
and here are some of the causes that
money is being raised for
there's the chess for people with
disabilities the feed a chess veterans
uh support and chess in education so
it's a really great initiative
sam the winning team you know it's going
to be declared
online champion but also the team that
raises the most money
for charity throughout the competition
is invited to the world championship
match
at the end of 2021 accommodation expense
is covered for three nights and vip
tickets provide to attend three rounds
of the match
that'll be pretty exciting for the team
that's able to give
the most back they'll also receive that
invitation to the world championship
yeah absolutely and i think this is one
of the initiatives that
you know is kind of behind the scenes
for many uh
who watch vida events watch the fide
world chess championship see
all that they do with ratings players
and managing titles and all that
but a lot of what fide does is really
connecting
with great causes to help promote chess
around the world and
companies who are able to really provide
that support
help with fundraising help with
sponsorship and a lot of the companies
that are
participating in this event have been
sponsors
of major chess events through feed 8 in
the past so this is
fantastic to see and it's a great
initiative to be
kind of bringing together with this
event along with some great chess some
great chess players
everything coming together in a really
really nice way
absolutely couldn't have said it better
myself and it is great that they are
raising
funds for these initiatives and it's a
friendly competition but we know that uh
with friendly competition you can take
out the friendly sometimes
there is some serious competition about
to go down and there may be rivalries
between
corporations there may just be friendly
rivalries between chess players
it's a nice mix and anish geary and
magus carlson well
if there's a rivalry you know they'll be
there for it
absolutely and as you say it's a
friendly competition
i often find that team uh formats you
know the olympiad u.s amateur team east
so many other team
events are both the friendliest and most
fun to play in
and they are also the ones where you're
most invested
right because in a normal tournament if
you draw
or you mess up and you lose it's okay
it's on you
you know you move on but when your team
is depending on your result
it really feels like the stakes just go
absolutely through the roof
and i know that a lot of players here
are really going to feel that pressure
as they need that extra half point that
extra full point to help their team get
through to the finals on sunday
i do believe that's something that can
be overlooked and as somebody who has
competed in so many team events
it's stressful honestly where you're
playing your board but you also have to
play the match situation
you're looking at board three this match
is tied one to one it's your board and
the third board left and
you're looking there is my teammate
winning are they doing okay
and the next thing you know oh your team
is in trouble so you have to change your
mindset and then play for a win just to
even the match up
there's a lot to juggle in these
situations sam so i think that could be
a difficult
thing to take under control for players
who are used to just playing casual
individual games
absolutely and normally when you're
playing classical
normally let's say that rapid is now
normal but
traditionally when you're playing a
classical tournament you have some time
to process what's going on
in your teammates games and it matters
it matters a lot maybe not so much today
tomorrow will matter a lot more in those
final rounds as we're seeing who's going
to get into the
actual finals on sunday right but
in attend to time control you really
aren't going to have a lot of time to
make assessments about your teammate's
boards and that does matter in this team
format it's going to be
very tense uh very exciting and we're
really looking forward to all of it
yeah it absolutely does and it's mainly
going to be fun
we don't want to put too much pressure
on any individual player
though some teams i'm sure have been
preparing a lot i know
in new york city there is a corporate
chess league and those
teams meet once a week and actually you
know we'll get
probably that conversation later in the
day when some of those teams play
but i know that it's a very fun
environment but
teams do have a lot of chess training so
i think that
ratings can be misleading in an event of
this magnitude
because they're full-time employees they
don't have time to play in all these
tournaments but they may be taking
lessons or
working within one another on their
chests absolutely and
looking through the list of players
there are so many players that i was
just
excited to see at this event players
like joel lattier who
is one of the best players you know in
the past
few decades was a top player from france
was really the top player
maybe before etienne backrow and maxine
by shiloh in france and he went
in a corporate career and has a great
job now
uh for the company he's going to be
representing here he's been working for
a long time
in the financial world and you know
he hasn't been playing chess in
i don't know 20 years at this point it's
exciting to see him in this event
competing with his co-workers and
colleagues
and i think too we have you know we have
magnus and anish we're going to focus a
lot on their games that's really
exciting but we also have companies in
here
who have players who are an average
rating of like 1500
where these are players who know each
other they play during their lunch break
and you know this is a big part of their
day-to-day
life along with the work that they're
doing together and i think that's really
really cool
it certainly is and i do love that
dynamic
it is kind of it's a building experience
i guess
they have these team building exercises
chemistry exercise right when you start
working together chess can be a unifying
force in that way
so i think that it's a great staple of
the office some of these teams do take
it very seriously a lot of them just
casual players and that's great and
there are many
good teams out there not just you know
the magnus carlson and each gears of the
world but players who
have loved the game for a long time and
just may not be able to play because
their profession takes them away but
speaking of anish i did speak to him
before the event quite extensively and
it is great to see that the
collaboration with optivar is a long
time thing he told me actually that
before he was involved they've had a
long chess history that included the
likes of john smates
and the uh and from optery they go to
tata steel
every single year to well not this year
of course because the pandemic but
they've been spectators that event
so their company really does love and
has a long tradition with chess
absolutely and there are a lot of
companies like that here who've been
sponsoring players
or who run events like grinka who's
going to be a favorite
in this event i think has a very good
chance to make it to the finals
tata has also represented major
companies who also have really invested
in chess and supported chess a lot over
many many years and i think that's
fantastic as well you mentioned anish
geary
optivare's first pairing in this event
is
akshay alpa i think i'm missing the
pronunciation a little bit i apologize
but they've been sponsoring nihal sarin
for a long time
one of the best young talents coming out
of india a player who i'm really excited
to see
you know uh in the next few years
especially especially as we get back to
over the board chess his rating was
skyrocketing and then we lost a lot of
over the board chess
and this is a player who feels like he
might be 2700 plus at this point
and his rating may just not really be
reflecting it because he hasn't had
rated tournaments
and i think aneesh tweeted that he's
anticipating playing nihal sauron in the
first round today
not an easy pairing at all in fact the
pairings only come out 10 minutes before
the games so we
don't know that nihal sauron's actually
in the lineup yet but it certainly seems
likely
now what a funny experience for these
high-level chess players
okay hey what are you doing this weekend
i'm taking part in this uh
feed egg online you know corporate world
chess championship
it should be pretty good i'm gonna play
uh players from other companies
and then guess what your first round
pairing is nihal sarin good luck to you
that's
no rest for these any player in this
field
including magnus carlsen there are so
many strong players out there
underrated players and it's going to be
a lot of fun but that is
a heavyweight matchup in the first round
absolutely it's really incredible how
many players
are playing in this event total and then
how many top players are also playing in
this event
um when i think the initial lineups came
out i think many were shocked to see you
know magnus carlson on each gary
all of these players there i know that
david yatta who's the press officer for
fide was on twitter and people were you
know buzzing about magnus carlson
playing in this event and he
was commenting you know he may not
organize events that often but when he
does he tries to bring world champions
uh and this is certainly a huge success
for him huge success for feed a
really a tremendous achievement and
exciting to see
all of the players and companies that
are represented in this whole event i
think we're going
to get a cut in on some of these players
uh in just a second
for sure and for everybody wondering
about the round start time just know
that there are
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
players all
calling into the you know fair play
calls their arbiters all around the
world taking
part in this making sure that the
integrity of the event is upheld
so there's a lot going on behind the
scenes the rounds will start shortly we
do appreciate your patience
and it's just you know it goes to show
with just what a team effort this is
from fide from
chess.com from many arbiters around the
world who are you know helping out and
there's a lot of tech that needs to be
taken care of so we do appreciate
everyone's effort here
absolutely i think that as chess players
who've played tournaments who've played
team tournaments before there's no
tournament that i
see maybe other than like the elementary
championships that impressed me more on
an organizational level than the team
tournaments
right you see the olympiad you see the
pro chess league which uh
we've been directly involved in the
complexity of that
you know you see your us amateur team
east so many players so many games
uh often you're dealing with you know
substitutions for players as you do have
reserves that you can call in and that
affects a lot of things
the tie breaks get crazy complicated and
teams need to understand that
you know that because you've been a
captain of the u.s
women's olympiad team and in this case
that's ramped up because everything is
online
so you don't have the players in the
building where you may be able to more
easily address some things
and the time control is 10-2 so just a
huge shout out
to all of the arbiters and organizers
involved
i know that there are some people who've
been tearing their their hair out
literally i know david yatta doesn't
have any left
to make this event happen yeah well it
is really a team effort
and we do appreciate everyone's input
their work
uh just it's phenomenal an event of this
magazine is taking place
and we are going to take a short break
just to get everything set
wait for the start of the round we will
be back very shortly when the rounds
will begin
and the feed a corporate chest
championship will begin
[Music]
and we are back getting set for the fide
corporate championship
to get underway here sam we know from
behind the scenes these zoom calls there
are many of them and there are
so many people in each room right uh
we are really stretching the limits of
zoom
to its full capacity we're going to show
one of the breakout rooms
right now this is again only one of the
breakout rooms
there are so many players participating
in this event of course we've got them
all on camera because of fair play
concerns
and you know just because we also want
to be able to show some of these players
in the broadcast and show their teams in
the broadcast so
i'm not actually sure which pool this is
at the moment but this is just one of
the breakout rooms
right here uh with so many players uh
setting up for their games getting ready
to start i heard that we are still
waiting on a fair number of players
which is why
some of the games most of the games all
the games i think actually haven't
started
uh but we're getting them all in and
addressing everybody i think you
commented
while we were on break that as
organizers and i think we've both
organized events there's never uh
a first round that really starts on time
and that's true right now
and that's just an expectation when you
go in especially with
a unique format like this we have
literally the best arbiters in the world
helping make this happen but it's a
first round
you know the players have all of the
information about how to get in how to
get set up and such but when you have
thousands of players
there's going to be some confusion you
know there are people who are struggling
with internet
or just don't they've never used zoom
before
right that happens in some cases and so
there's a lot to be sorted and
you know it's all coming together but
it's taking maybe a few more minutes
for sure and the priority is definitely
make sure that everyone has a good time
and everyone has a fair time and
if somebody you know can't get in for to
the zoom link for some reason or if
there's an outage in some area you don't
want to see a team forfeited and because
they have spaced out the rounds
they're you know the rounds don't start
one on top of the other
that leaves some wiggle room and i think
it's good that everyone
is able to participate and play in the
opening round but of course i know there
are a lot of eager fans out there saying
wait my my company's playing i want to
root on my teammates you know my
co-workers and others who just have a
favorite player who may be playing of
course
we've mentioned magnus carlson ishkiri
yon napan mashi vice lover temie of
some of the who's who of the chess world
taking part so it's a nice
balance of these teams from different
companies as well as top players so i'm
sure there are a lot of
people running let us know in the chat
honestly let us know who you're rooting
for if you're part of a company
it's great to engage with you all
absolutely there are so many players and
teams in this event we're not going to
be able to focus on all of them
but we would really love to know which
players and teams you would like us to
focus on
there are so many players and teams as
well i think that
maybe aren't teams that people are
familiar with that are actually likely
to be favorites because they just have
a lot of depth um you know there's a lot
of great chess players who also have
great careers these companies and you
may not hear their name very often
because you know they've got this career
that's really been a fantastic focus
and they're not as active as they were
five years ten years ago something like
that
you know who are some of the teams that
are kind of standing out to you
that might be missed early on but really
have a lot of depth and could really go
the distance here
well you and i were actually talking off
stream just during our break
and i was saying that paypal bulgaria
they have a great team
featuring sergei erenberg grand master
on board one
and then on board two they have uh
antares stefanova the
former women's world champion so they
have a very
top-heavy team but then you look down
their roster and even their board 4 is
rated
21 30 feet a and we were talking about
some of these ratings can be misleading
sometimes people are rusty so they'll be
overrated right it's a
former rating and they can't quite live
up to that standard or they're
underrated because they still practice
they still train and they just don't
play in tournaments to get that rating
higher so that team
looks very dangerous and i would also
say the team from gronke
as you mentioned with george meyer on
the top board and i believe they brought
in
kashlinskaya on board too and the rest
of the way they have a very strong
lineup so i mean what about you sam do
you agree with those two teams or have
more caught your eye as well
a hundred percent of course these teams
are fantastic
i mean the grinca team is uh very
similar
uh in line up to the team that um
that germany put together in the
pro-chess league they've got george
meyer in there they've got hannah marie
kleck
uh they've got inna agrest and that team
did really well
the snowballs went to the finals in the
protest league so they're very familiar
with this format this time control
and they are going to be definitely you
know one of the toughest teams to beat
a top seed uh and an experienced seed
and i i definitely am looking forward to
watching them throughout this whole
event
uh absolutely you mentioned paypal
bulgaria um
morgan stanley from hungary has uh
levon brigadza an international master
uh
two more international masters that are
on board three and four robert
torma and oh i'm not going to get the
name
uh the pronunciation correct here
ryosuke nanjo and then
women's grandmaster petra pop who i'm
going to guess
is related to gabor pop who's i think
been the
coach of the hungarian national team so
i don't know if he's involved in the
coaching there but that's another team
that
has just a lot of depth is definitely
going to be very strong
wasco from poland has voitachic on board
one
a huge player and again they have a lot
of depth there another international
master on that board
there are just so many players in this
event
um that are you know very very strong
players v-day masters international
masters
you know grand masters who you might not
be familiar with because
they're super talented but they
discovered that it's possible to make a
lot more money
uh in an excellent corporate career than
as a grand master in many many cases
we should also just mention optivaire
with anish gary we've been mentioning on
ishgary
obviously he's incredible you know one
of the top seeds in this event
we've been talking about how much depth
matters optivaire
has also got feeding master javier
alcarez alsarez on board two
and david pardo simon an international
master here on board three
those orders might be incorrect i think
some of the chess results orders
might not actually be the accurate board
orders i'm not 100 sure
and they have a 1 000 rated player
lucrezia
minoncello on board four i have a
feeling
i have a feeling as strong as this team
is that this 1000 rating
is actually just you know a filler
number
that this player may not have played
rated chess before but i have a feeling
that he's going to be
much much better than 1000 and
optivar could really be a contender you
know if they have a niche
an international master of feeding
master here and a 1000
where i'm just not going to buy that
lucretia is actually 1 000. if a niche
picks you for his team
then i have a feeling that you might
have some skills
or it's the person who has a lot of
pressure on them but the games are off
and speaking of a thousand rate of
players
you're 1 000 rated player we have here
maksat der dayev is playing against
vladislav artemyev can you imagine
you are coming into this corporate
championship you're saying
hey i'm i'm competing world championship
at stake
and my first round opponent is none
other than vladislav artemyev
one of the absolute best players in the
world we've seen him uh
take down huge names in the speed chess
championship among other events
and now with the white pieces and look
you see that evaluation bar
slightly better for white if you're a
co-worker
of uh this player here take a photo and
say you were
better after nine moves slightly against
one of the top players in the world of
lightsabers mef
absolutely i think that uh someone
posted on twitter when they saw magnus
carlsen's first round pairing and we'll
look at that game as that game gets
started later
where he's playing a 1400 opponent an
interesting question for this opponent
and this opponent right here with maxat
playing against vladislav artemyev
is do you consider yourself you know the
luckiest player in the event
you're playing one of the best chess
players in the world this is such a rare
opportunity
um or are you thinking oh man this is so
unlucky
you know i personally think that you
have to be thinking i'm so lucky i'm
playing one of the best players in the
event
you know my team is probably not going
to make the finals
but i'm here to have a really good time
to represent my company
and i get to do that against an amazing
player who i admire and respect
it's a once-in-a-lifetime experience for
many of them because a player like
artemia or geary or
magnus we're talking about you don't get
an opportunity to play them unless it's
an assignment but in a one-on-one game
this is a rare opportunity and i don't
think that they'll take it for granted
and we'll talk about this game briefly
here um artemia just played with a5 so
he's taking space over on the queen side
and he has this wonderful bishop on g7
slicing across the board
and for durdave here he hasn't finished
his development
and because black has this bishop on g7
white can't push d4 very easily
and if you play c3 you try to take over
the center with d4
not so fast because black is first to
play the move like b4 but look at him he
strikes
i like day four yeah me too but then b4
has played and
i think sam you also really love that
bishop one g7 i really do love that
bishop on g7 i wish the rook wasn't on
a1 so i could play b3 it wouldn't solve
all the issues
uh but it would help it would help to be
able to lock up
a bit of a light square blockade i think
that
a lot of players are often frustrated
with these
kind of setups here this isn't exactly i
guess it's a closed sicilian here
a lot of amateur players like setups
like white is going for here
usually i think the f pawn is going to
be on f4 which will help with some
counter play
um but i think seeing how our team yeah
is approaching this position is really
instructive
you know very natural play and this is
the kind of play that many players could
plug in when they're facing a similar
system
for white also since he's not since that
he's not being impatient he's not trying
to
like run over his opponent he's a much
more experienced player
he knows that his chances are going to
come and he's just putting his pieces on
good squares
taking space where he can and he knows
that eventually the game will turn
absolutely and this knight came to h2 i
expected to come to g4
which to some of our viewers may seem
very threatening that night's coming to
the king side maybe in city score like
age six
but artemio is fully developed he has a
connectivity between all the pieces here
no weaknesses to speak of and a move
like rook b1 hey sam your idea with b3
is coming soon that would also protect
that pawn on a4
the queen is eyeing that although i tell
me if he could play in the center he
could push his pawn to d5 to take up
space
he can play pawn f5 which is a move you
don't want to play unless you're sure
and confident
in that because it opens up your king a
bit but look rookie e8 rook f8 i do
expect
a pawn push to f5 so i was really liking
f5
absolutely um i i play the dutch defense
so if i play as questionable an f5 move
as is the dutch defense i'm definitely
going to be looking to play f5 in this
position
you know create more pressure here with
that bishop on b7 which doesn't look
like it's doing a lot right now
but when you push that f pawn it's
really going to
start to count and i love that he's put
his
rooks in place before he's pushed the
pawns
you know that's not always going to be
kind of the right strategy
but i just have a penchant for that kind
of build up
setting up and then you just start to
crash through and that's what he's doing
right now
and it's very very powerful um you see
that even though
no pieces have been exchanged white
hasn't made any
you know material errors at this point
the computer's already really liking
black and that's just an indication of
the great class of player
that our team yet is and the way that
he's mobilizing his full pieces here
and he played h6 did not allow the queen
to d2 to line up with the bishop on the
diagonal instead
we see it capturing e7 now black is the
bishop pair watch out there's already a
direct threat easy to miss that because
that knight in c6
simply recaptured a piece but now it's
easy to overlook wait let's at the
corner of my eye there's a pawn there
that needs to be taken care of so
b3 probably should be played but now
this bishop is even stronger it doesn't
have a counterpart
so i think artemyev well he can now just
take this pawn unfortunately
dudaya who's been playing a good game
all these moves have been quite
principled in nature
now it's going to be a material deficit
not just a positional one so i think
that our team's do you take that pawn
though
like or do you kind of push forward and
stay focused in the middle of the board
i agree in principle that taking the
pawn is an excellent decision and you
have the
pawn in pocket i don't know i just
i've never wanted to play very greedily
i guess he's he's gonna do it you're
always right
well you know i think you're also
correct to say that maybe there was
something to play in the center
you know black could have played with h5
to kick this night out first if that
night looks scary
but i'll tell you if he calculates he
says it's free let me take it
and also it's nice to see that artemis
isn't just playing every move in a as a
pre-move
not playing bullet chess here playing a
serious game giving
respect and that's the sign of a true
professional where you play the board
the position
not the rating of your opponent he might
not even know the rating honestly he
might have just said
all right i'm playing for my team let's
do this so uh artemia steals a pawn
moves his queen back and i think we
should move on to the game between anish
giri
and nihal sarin here because that's a
really heavyweight matchup and it's
round one
no rest for either player and you see
the ratings next to the name nihal sard
2593 i think we can agree
a little underrated huh you know
tata steel just finished and we saw
jordan van furies win that event of
course we know jordan's a great player
but that surprised a lot of people uh
you were commentating that event so you
got to see
all of that firsthand we also saw
alireza farouja
andre essepinko have a great result in
that event and one of the things that i
kind of took away watching tata steel
was we haven't had any chance for most
of these super
talented players to really play rated
chess they're so young they're so
talented we see nihal soren's rating
here of 25.93
how accurate is that if he had a full
slate
of feed-a-rated games in 2020 early 2021
would he maybe be upper 2600s would he
maybe be
already possibly over 2700 we've seen
peers
of his like ali reza farouja make that
break
and he's really impressed in some online
settings in 2020 2021
the junior speed chess championship is
definitely one of the biggest ones where
he was
you know playing absolutely amazing
crushing chess
and a lot of situations and he's just
going to be very very tough
as an opponent here for anish geary the
computer's saying
it's dead equal but this is such an
imbalanced position with white having
this
extended somewhat fractured pawn
structure but some initiative and
activity in return
uh i think a draw is actually not that
likely here
at this point you know in a rapid game
we can definitely see a lot of things
happen from this point
and i'm sure the spectators are thrilled
to hear that because they don't like
draws
and what sam is saying is that this
queen on f4 this king on g7 right that
looks like a potential attack in the
making for white
but anisha's claim is look at your c3
pawn look at your a2
those are split pawns best friend being
another pawn they feel better protected
that way
and anisha is just doing very
fundamentally sound chess
this bishop can go to the longest
diagonal on the board bishop to b7
or it can come to a6 if there you need a
tempo and this rook is under attack on
f1
so you have a choice of where to put the
bishop the rooks will likely size
one to c8 one to d8 and i guess sam
is this going to be enough for nihal
sarin because he wants to play the move
h5
he played h4 but how are you going to
line this queen and this bishop up for a
checkmating attack
i think the whole point of h5 of course
is to soften this light square diagonal
but it really seems like black has total
control over that diagonal that knight
on c5 looks amazing
um and yes the bishop is coming to b7
you can't set up a queen e4
uh battery if you manage to push h5
which seems like it's going to be met
fairly comfortably by g5 whose position
would you prefer here i feel like this
is a bit of a litmus test
i see the computer saying it's really
close to balanced
i would play pick black in a heartbeat
um that may be just my stylistic
preference i don't know what yours is
well based on the time consumption where
anish giri is down on the clock he is
less than five minutes this could get
sharper
i will say that he seems worried i would
also take black's position i like the
long-term benefits of the position
but i'm just trying to think is h4 is
that point to play h5 or maybe there
could be this sneaky
knight reroute nh2 knight g4 because
there's a soft square on f6
that is under white's control so you
have to be careful about things like
that
and i admit that when i first looked i
thought that black's position looked
excellent of course i can see the
evaluation but not the moves and it says
about level and if that's the case about
level that it's clear that
white has some attacking chances
otherwise i think the position
or the evaluation i should say would
favor black and this 9 h2 knight g4 idea
is of course
really creative and interesting on the
other hand if you do knight h29 g4 you
would drop the pawn on h4 in this
particular moment
like if you were able to get those two
moves in in a row and to make that pawn
secure you might need to play g3 but
that
weakens the light squares so much do you
really want to do that that
seems like a very committal decision
yeah i
won't say that i would like to do that
maybe if i'm trying to attack i
i will have to and bishop a6 played by
niche and that tells me that he feels
the need to
develop very quickly instead of playing
bishop b7 on a great diagonal right i'm
talking about that
he says let me gain a tempo and that
means he gains
a move to figure out his plan here
because the rook is under attack and
that rook is more valuable than the
bishop that rook
should slide out the way and then anish
can put a rook on the d8 square so sam
what is something on d3 potentially i
would love to sink the bishop or knight
into d3 i
really am behind that square thinking of
great games like grunfeld versus
al jekyn and other games where a knight
is sunk into d3
of course uh karpov or uh carpe vs
kasparov game 16 1985.
you know this is a bit of a different
structure but these games have really
made me
you know cherish any opportunity to
stick a powerful piece into a big square
like d3
and i again the computer's saying that
there's
you know good play for white and if i
were evaluating this and i could not see
the computer evaluation
i would definitely be telling like a
student that this is slight advantage
clear advantage for black
um yeah i am completely with you and
we do see that evaluation uh so it says
slightly better for white so i'm
guessing that some kind of like
rook d1 rook d4 try to take over the
open file that's also something
we would tell our students right there's
an open file that's the fully open and
he plays rook
e1 and the evaluation stays about the
same so
sam i was going to ask you this one of
the important is the evaluation bar
stuck
that's not the question i was going to
ask you but that is possible it's not on
a
high depth but sometimes you need to
figure out what pieces should be traded
and
each uses your idea of bishop d3 because
if the knight recaptured that would be a
fork
on the queen the rook but what pieces
does white need for a potential attack
and for black what pieces would you like
to see traded to feel more confident in
your position
uh i guess i would like to see all the
pieces traded
if i'm black and i just win the end game
based on structure
um for white i think you want all the
pieces on the board which is what we're
seeing with bishop to b3 and of course
black doesn't want to take on b3 and fix
the pawn structure there for white
then white would actually be probably
just much much better
and of course you know anish is never
going to take on b3 unless there's a
specific
tactical reason that he can make that
work some game he's getting uh
in this position i think if i could
trade
all the minor pieces and leave white
with the structure that he has i would
feel really good about the heavy piece
in game
i would love to get that heavy piece in
game because the rooks and the queen are
so good at press pressuring like the
isolated pawn on c3
that probably if you trade all of the
minor pieces
i'm starting to think that this could be
like almost a technical win for black
that might be optimistic on my part but
i've always had
a real penchant for pressuring these uh
these positions
uh with the heavy pieces and by pension
i mean
affection not skill i screw it up all
the time
but i really like trying to pressure
with the the heavy pieces and these
kinds of thing games
well optiver might be a little bit
nervous right now that bar
went up to over plus one for white
despite the even material
and i really like the last couple moves
that nihal has played and if we actually
go back i just want to show a quick
tactical sequence
that was possible is that knight takes
b3 pawn takes b3 that knight hits the
rook and the corner you have to take
back
and it looks like you steal a pawn with
rook takes c3 but you'll notice that
this bishop on d3 is under attack
once owned defended once and moved like
queen to d4
hits this rook on c3 while hitting this
bishop on d3 a second time
and that would win white that bishop on
the spot
very instructive moment and great play
from nihal sarin as he's making a move
that he wants to play rookie 3
lifting that rook it's not immediately
clear how that rook might be involved in
the attack but it's much better
positioned to create some very serious
threats
on e3 than it was on e1
so he improved his position he also
asked some serious questions of
anishgiri in terms of his setup
and what he was trying to do with bishop
d3 and you know he managed to defend an
attacked pawn with these tactics
very very instructive play very
impressive play from nihal sarin
and it is starting to feel more and more
dangerous from a niche
uh anisha's perspective both players
down to
two and a half minutes or they're about
under three minutes
i think one thing that's going to be
interesting to see in this event
is how the players manage their time
this 10-2
time control is really popular for a lot
of amateurs in fact a lot of amateurs
the most popular time control on
chess.com is 10 minutes flat
that shocks a lot of people you know
grandmasters
stronger players often pick three minute
five minute or bullet
but the most popular time control in
chess.com is 10 minutes flat
so for amateur players this is a very
natural time control
for professional players i think it's
often a very difficult time control to
play
and you see them kind of consuming a lot
of time early in the game
trying to get that advantage look at
that turn of events here i mean the bar
just dropped and that was a huge drop
and the reason why
was because of anisha's wonderful move
queen g5 i mean look at this
just to go back very quickly h5 goes for
the attack and he says i don't want to
play g5 my king is unsafe let me play
queen g5
your e5 pawn your c3 pawns those are
things i'm going to target
and we saw the trait of queens and now
we've seen a trait of another pair of
pawns so right
and look at that final move of the
sequence bishop c4
defending the e6 pawn attacking the a2
pawn
and this pawn f7 isn't going anywhere
and he knows that so he can capture that
next move so improving a piece
rather than recapturing for the sake of
recapturing i like the way niche is
playing it but
now let me ask you sam we've talked
about these bad pawns or potentially
weak pawns on the queen side
for white blacks king side pawns are a
bit split too now
i don't feel as concerned about black's
kingside pawns though because
the king is near them for one thing it
feels like those can be
very uh comfortably defended they're
also not
on files where white's rook can attack
them very easily
i mean you can try and bring some
pressure against e6 but it's challenging
bishop b3 feels good
and it seems like the computer's saying
all right this is likely to kind of
liquidate out to a balanced position um
of course right now it's still very very
complicated
i noticed we have the nishon camera you
know he definitely seemed like he was
under pressure and then as soon as h5
happened he immediately played queen g5
and my sense from his body language
was he had really been hoping for that
move that he felt like he was under
pressure and he
you know kind of banged out the moves up
through bishop c4
he had seen all of this and had been
feeling much more comfortable about this
notion of h5 as soon as he got queen g5
in
and i think anish is feeling great in
the moment and this is where experience
and practice pays off because
anish has played in the tata steel over
the board tournament he had a great
showing time for first ultimately losing
in the armageddon playoff to his
compatriot jordan von forrest but
he also then played in the champions
chess tour he is fresh he's ready to go
and now in this end game the king is
better placed for black i actually like
black's position
and look at the clock a minute 47 for a
niche just
under a minute now for nihal sarin and
this is not an
easy draw despite the zeros on the
evaluation bar
rookie one there could be a tactic or
the rook takes e5 removing the defender
the bishop on c4
so there's a lot to figure out and not
that much time to do so
does rook takes e5 work if black is able
to include bishop takes b3 obviously
it's a tactical idea
but in this moment okay well it's off
the table now so we've got the trade on
b3 and white structure has improved a
little bit
and now white also has the ability to
pressure uh
on the a file against the pawn on a7
although that's not the direction that
nihal went he lifts the rook to e3
um and now nihal has the better pawn
structure for the first time this game
he's got two pawn islands
and anish has three yes and well this
time situation is one where niche is up
half a minute but nihilson's one of the
best
bullet players on the planet so bullet
play is
under one minute hyper bullet 30 seconds
and so
nielsen he's used to this look at these
moves played very quickly but knight c6
i think this might peter out you know
earlier it didn't seem like a draw was
likely now if we get a trade of knights
it's a rook end game it shouldn't be an
advantageous for either side
although with the time advantage perhaps
that could be in black's favor but
ultimately
it looks like a position that should
just be level it does feel like we're
heading to a draw at this point
i'm curious do you think that nihal
sauron has an edge and bullet i often
think that
junior players like mihal soren who have
played a lot of bullet and he's really
really good
are kind of given this edge over players
like anish
from pundits and a lot of times i don't
think that's true all right well we get
the draw
we get the draw so neither player is
testing it at this point no
so let's uh move on from anisha's game
we'll go to sergey aronberg playing and
it looks like he has a winning end game
at this point this bishop
dark squares look at all these pawns
thank you very much i'm gonna play
pac-man
on the king side i'm gonna take all your
pawns you can even take those two
queenside pawns off the board and white
still wins
um classic structure here where the
bishop gets in
all the pawns are on the wrong color and
it is unfortunately a disaster for black
of course
white was up a couple of pawns white was
playing you know in tough situation in a
tough situation
against a grand master outraged by uh
hundreds and hundreds of points not
quite a thousand points but obviously
ehrenberg was a huge favorite but this
is still instructive to see that that
bishop go after those pawns
for sure and ehrenberg part of that
paypal bulgaria team that we mentioned
earlier
very strong lineup nice to get off to a
good start of course he has 800 rating
points
on his opponent but when you are a bit
rusty and you're a full-time employee
at a job like he has you know you want
to
just get back in rhythm and that can be
true no matter your opponent you
are much more focused on the level of
play that you're showing
and here he's winning this easily h6 the
knight will have to set oh look at that
that is fine technique the knight wanted
to come to g5
to stop the pawn before it got to a
light square and the bishop couldn't
defend
so it plays f4 to take away the square
the best you can do now is give up your
knight
for the pawn and well this is an easy
conversion at this point
fantastic grand grandmaster patients um
you know with a player like ehrenberg
i feel like he's a player who was ranked
a bit more highly a while back
and now he's got this great career he's
representing his company in this event
and i think that there are a number of
players in this event who might be
stronger
and more challenging opponents in this
rapid format i think we've seen this
sometimes in the protest league
or the us chess league before that where
these players
no longer have the time to study a lot
of theory but
they still have these great instincts
and they might be 50 to 100 points off
of their peak rating but when it comes
down to rapid
you know they just still have that
tremendous talent and can really be
you know a challenge for magnus carlson
anish geary
i think that we might see a player like
ehrenberg potentially score a point
against one of these superstars in this
event
and aaron berg is a player who i have
faced off against a number of times
he's very well respected he's an
extremely solid player difficult to beat
and doesn't take unnecessary risk so
sometimes a player
you know will have an identical rating
to another player but their styles
are just very wildly different in fact
and ehrenberg is known for his solid
play
and that could be difficult for some of
these top players because he will not
just let you win he's not going to do
something uh just out of the blue
to sacrifice a piece for no reason no he
is going to say if you are going to beat
me
you're going to use every fiber of your
being to do so right
and that's obviously as you say very
very tough
um and these top players uh
these 2700 plus players may feel like
they have to win
even though it's just going to be a very
very tough task we may at some point see
some players
over pressing trying to do that you know
it's often
maybe not going to be just about the
match circumstance they may feel like
their team can win the match but they
need to rack up as many match points as
possible because that is a critical tie
break
and essential to getting into the finals
on sunday
and uh we have another interesting end
game here
this is an example where the position
looks i think
to you know maybe an amateur eye like it
almost might be a draw white has an
extra palm but everything looks
blockaded
but it's light square bishop versus
light square bishop and black's pawns
are on the light squares
even if you take the pawn off of g3
eventually you're going to get zug's
wing
and you would win very very
instructively it's pretty amazing that
this pawn on g3 is an extra pawn but
that's not the important part
right of the game and oh see looks i'm
choosing a game that's not from this
competition there's so many
games here i was like hey let me just
click this this game that's here but
it's not part of the competition but
still a really fascinating one with
grandmaster alex delchev
and he's going to win this game with the
king to e5 so
[Laughter]
my bad my bad i clicked on a game that's
uh not part of this so
oh i love it if you were like there's a
grandmaster here versus a 2100
rated opponent this has got to be yeah
i'm just you know clicking on things
here you know here's
uh uh alvira baron playing i mean
i have a link to work with that should
help everything out but
i'm just doing my best everybody i'm
sorry let me oh
that didn't work
so yeah we're going to fix this that's
on my end now i ruined everything
if a producer can help me out that would
be awesome
i ruined everything
so you know i'm double checking this i
might be saying something that's wrong
here as we're kind of figuring some of
these things
out and i'll just take that heat if i'm
wrong but um
i think i saw that carissa yep is a
reserve on a team
um i'm curious about that
i'm trying to double check for american
express
american express you know there we go
and the reason that i was thinking about
that connection is because we were just
looking at grandmaster ehrenberg's game
and i know that uh carissa
defeated grandmaster aaron berg in her
first win
over a grand master which made a lot of
press at the time as it should have
in american circles and in fact she
covered that game on
chess kit she did a video on it it was
really very very instructive she won a
beautiful game in the dragon sicilian
against
grandmaster ehrenberg ivanov
ivanov grandmaster i believe was their
first win
maybe i could be wrong i could be wrong
but i think
it was against yvonne if i'm remembering
correctly maybe
i i swear it was uh carissa yet versus
ehrenberg but maybe it wasn't her first
win maybe it was a
different win but i'm i'm almost uh 100
certain that there's a video of her
victory on chess kid
if not you know people can castigate me
i'm cool it's the internet what is it
here for if not for castigating people
um so if i'm wrong please do correct me
yes my apologies everybody again for
my technological mishaps but also we
have board four for optivert we said she
might be
underrated lacrissia and she's winning
she's completely winning at somebody
who's
writing here is a little bit higher than
hers at least on the chess.com server
and she is about to deliver checkmate as
in
a queen and a rook ahead and
well this pawn can also just take and
create a new queen
instead she takes towards the king
giving it a check and i think this
hopefully can we look at this game
quickly kind of from the beginning
because i'm really curious about her
skill level in representing
optivaire um because she's the lowest
rated
player on optivaire which is the team
that anish giri is representing
but she's looking great in that final
position obviously she's winning you
know she
um seems to be playing much much better
than her kind of initial rating here
uh so it's what you'll see right at the
lower levels is just you know newer
players sometimes they put pieces and
squares they don't realize that under
attack
and it seems like she just took all the
pieces that were given to her i mean
just that's the way you want to go and
look at that she found a nice
night retreat to work on the pin and one
very important queen takes e4 would have
dropped the checkmate
all right you see that bar plummet that
would have been a blunder and instead
took with the
knight on e4 at this point and then put
all the piece of safety took
everything that was offered so can't
complain about this if you're a niche in
team optivar
she's really maximizing this game
there's the bishop that's hanging on c5
and she takes on d5 first there's the
knight that's hanging on b6
and she goes i think she captured on e6
first or something
so she's uh taking everything that's on
offer and then
other things before she takes those
things on offer so
she's definitely going to be a player
that we're going to be watching closely
in this event because
optivar's a team that's really going to
be contending to get into that final on
sunday
and her performance is really going to
be very important of course
anish giri is a player that whose games
we're going to be watching closely we
love
watching on each play but how she's able
to perform might be
the key to them getting through and of
course we should give her credit you
know
she's gotta win and anish kerry does not
you know so we just gotta
make sure that we recognize that i was
like where you going with this
now i see what you did there i see what
you did so uh it seems like
board four leading this team not board
one so niche absolutely
black and white should be team captain
yes and well
checkmate in two queen b6 this is
actually a very important position for
those of you who are newer to chess this
king is trying to escape away here
so putting your queen on b6 it stops the
king's escape and the next move will be
rook to d8 i think our
temptation sam is to rookie 7's also a
good move going
for the eventual checkmate but our
temptation is to give checks rather than
thinking about where that king will run
to once we give the checks
absolutely um something that i often
explain to
uh amateur students to scholastic
students that are starting out
is that checkmate is a check that you
cannot escape
the hard part is the cannot escape part
the check
part is the easy part and the check part
is the part that at the amateur level
players focus on
and they just check check check check
and then you have queen versus king
in the end game and you actually never
make progress and it's a 50 move rule
draw
in scholastic competitions the key is
covering the escape squares and of
course rook d7
did that very nicely and of course your
move queen b6 was even more precise
yes and the king walked towards the rook
and that's why checkmate was here
but if the king had gone to a7 there
wouldn't be a checkmate just yet though
still rook d7 a very good move
with purpose the queen can just line up
against his b7 pawn
and you can take advantage of a pin
queen c6 says you can't take the queen
that pawn legally cannot move there the
next move will be queen takes pawn and
checkmate
yes very very nice technique okay
well we do have it seems that the
first round here the games have
been finished i just want to check on
that so i i've already clicked on games
that may or may not have been part of
this term actually was informed that it
was part of the tournament so i wasn't
in the wrong
i'm just gonna i'm just saying i'm not
gonna blame anybody else but it just
wasn't completely my fault many things
are though
uh i was sitting here and i was like
really this event this game and this
time control isn't part of the event it
feels like it should be i was with you i
i wanted to believe in you but
in either case it was a an interesting
moment and a beautiful end game really a
beautiful
same colored bishop in game and a nice
technique there from grand master del
chef
yeah i should have trusted my my first
god and then i just got on my own head
but
either way we do have the results in the
books and we are going to take some time
here
group there are more rounds today so you
should know the schedule of this
tournament
it's not just oh this match is done
there's no more chess there's a lot of
chess to be played
so we have a couple more rounds in these
pools from the east
then later uh well tonight my time i
don't know where everyone else is
watching from
but uh in the night time in new york and
the evening time in the pacific there
will be more
chess to be played in the other pool so
a lot of chess left uh we're gonna
sign up for now but sam any uh last
parting words before we get ready for
the
second round of matches not really
uh i would just generally say that this
is a lot of fun
it's chaotic it's chaotic for the
players it's chaotic for us but there
are a lot of great games being played
by great players i would mention to
everyone
it's impossible to watch all of these
10-2 games at the same time
literally impossible but if you want to
make sure that you catch
your favorite players and their games in
this event go check out chess.com
events there is a page there for every
single pool here
the six eastern pools a b c d e and f
and the two pulls the western pools that
are be playing tonight
uh and you can search your favorite
players find their games
go through those uh it'll be an easy way
to keep tabs
on all of the players uh playing in this
event who you really want to follow
for sure and we will be back in about 30
minutes for the second round we want to
remind everyone one last time
well not last time we'll keep reminding
you but for now that this is
an event raising money for charity
please do click the link
on the panels there on twitch and if you
can of course
that we'd appreciate the generosity but
for now we're going to sign off we will
be back
in about a half hour getting ready for
the second round of the
feed a online corporate chess
[Music]
championship
you